[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
from all of us here at zenimax online
Studios I'd like to welcome everyone
around the world to the eso Legacy the
bretton's autumn event
before we dive into all the news and
updates coming to the Elder Scrolls
Online in the next few months I want to
take a moment to thank and celebrate
with you all it is humbling to realize
that we've added over 2 million new
players in just this past year alone
a huge thank you to all our communities
for your continued support and a warm
welcome to our new Spanish friends who
have joined since we added the Spanish
text localization this past June being
able to enjoy your favorite game in your
native language is important to us and
we're thrilled to bring simplified
Chinese text localization coming with
the release of the firesong DLC this
November it's not just the new languages
that's fueling our continued growth one
of our design goals at zoss is to make
games so they can be enjoyed by everyone
regardless of how much or how little you
have played before
we've built ESO to be welcoming to all
players from the PVP focused to solo PVE
to group PVE and everything in between
for the past eight years we've taken
players on Many Adventures some spanning
multiple years others focused on a
single year
this year's Adventure has focused on the
bretons a noble race and one never
before explored deeply in any Elder
Scrolls game up to this point in the
Breton Saga we've launched two dungeon
dioces and a huge chapter update called
high aisle that contains a new Zone and
tons of new quests
now we're preparing for this year's
finale the eso fire song DLC and just
like any other content update to our
massive world you won't need to have
played anything before in order to enjoy
the Standalone experience a good portion
of today's stream will touch on that
final DLC in the legacy of the Breton
storyline there will be a deep dive into
the zone and the team will share behind
the scenes details in terms of themes
and influences but we're not just
focusing on that we've got announcements
details on upcoming in-game events free
content for all ESO players and more
so once again welcome to everyone around
the world there are nearly infinite
number of ways to play ESL it's a living
breathing virtual world with one of the
most welcoming communities in gaming
it's easy to jump in and start having
fun regardless of your experience with
the lore or gameplay style there is
literally something for every type of
player and that's why this stream and
this game isn't just for existing
players it's truly for everyone and so
now let's get things started enjoy the
show
hi everyone welcome to the legacy of the
bretton's autumn event we are so excited
to be with you live from this beautiful
Studio at Bethesda and we are so excited
to see so many of you joining us from
around the world first we would like to
introduce ourselves my name is Gina
Bruno I am the senior community manager
for The Elder Scrolls online and I am
very excited to introduce my co-host
today Kevin
hi everyone I'm Kevin I'm the Forum
manager um if you've been on the forums
you've probably seen zoss Kevin that's
me you're not saying the Flesh and the
Flesh and I'm Not Alone
um we've got ours only Jason here with
us hello everyone uh I'm Jason Barnes
I'm one of the Zone leads uh on ESO in
fact I'm the Zone lead for fire song
that's coming out and part of the show
is about
um just real quick brief background
about me
um so I've worked on a number of DLC and
chapters as lead uh starting with this
the one that involved this guy right
above me uh Mr Cal granted uh dragon
hold Blackwood and fire song and then
just as a designer since I've been with
zoss forever I helped her through a city
and made class balmora and Morrowind and
a bunch of other stuff Somerset and then
also helped create a bunch of characters
like nari Varian and my boy Darian
um so yes free Darion I see the chat
already so but yeah I'm super stoked to
be here and like not at my desk in my
house with my dogs jumping up on me so
yeah it's it's nice to actually be in a
studio yeah without all the distractions
of being at home and it's it's been a
while since we got to do this together
so we really appreciate everyone tuning
in today
um just to kind of go over some
housekeeping things we did want to
remind everybody that we do have twitch
drops on right now so be sure oh hello
uh make sure you link your um ESO and
twitch accounts for a chance to get that
clouded sench leopard cub pet and an
oroborus Crown crate all you have to do
is watch for at least 15 minutes and if
you watch for at least 30 minutes we are
actually going to be giving everyone an
extra urebors Crown crate but of course
we hope you stick around for the entire
show
so Kevin let's kind of go through
everything that we are going to be
discussing during today's stream yeah
definitely uh so first we're going to be
going through a fire song Dev Deep dive
um so we'll be talking all things Zone
characters uh you name it everything
fire song
um the whole journey so far
um we'll also have a Gameplay trailer uh
to show everybody and we'll be talking
about the fire song prologue Quest
now we did launch the heroes of high
Isle in-game event earlier today so we
will be going through and giving more
information on all the rewards for that
event we know you're looking forward to
finding out what the mysterious reward
is
um we actually have our web content
manager Dominic Navy's in-game on pcna
he's hanging out with some of our
players having a little dance party
um look at them all go he is over at
gone Fallen Bay in high Isle and this is
where you want to go if you want to get
started with Heroes of high aisle the
in-game event so you can head there to
either start the event or maybe just
hang out with Domino's friends have a
dance party it'll be a good time it
looks fun it's already a good time calm
down kids call the guard so
um we'll also be going over some details
on some sales on the base game and the
chapter that are actually live right now
uh we'll also be talking about some
in-game events and community activities
that are upcoming for ESL so with all
that said we know everyone's anxious to
get started so let's Dive Right In all
right just to quickly recap the legacy
of the Brenton's year-long Adventure
from this year we did start with the
ascending tide deal LC way back at the
beginning of the year this was two
four-player dungeons shipwrights regret
and coral Arie and then of course we
launched the high Isle chapter in June
yeah and with the high aisle chapter it
was really cool for us uh and hopefully
everyone playing it because we got to
dive kind of deep into Bren lore and
culture and a lot of their history and
the politics that are involved in bread
and houses and you know where they're
where they've come from it's not
something that we've really been able to
do since we touched on a little bit in
glenumbra but for the most part you know
this is our first chance to really deep
dive into bread and culture and who they
are and where they came from we also got
to explore High Isle and ominos which
are two new islands that you've only
kind of seen tiny little spot on the map
of uh but you never actually really got
to go there so got to create those for
everyone and uh yeah I was just very
cool experience for the dev team we hope
everyone who has played it has enjoyed
it so far and then just recently we came
out with the our quarter three lost
steps down dungeons DLC which featured
Craven deep in Earthen root Enclave as
well as a couple characters who may be
important to the story of fire song
coming up yeah I mean that's a ton of
stuff that we've been able to do so far
in the legacy of the bretons what has
been your favorite part so far
personally I've really enjoyed the what
the community has done with companions
you all raising and lowering reporters
of Companions and reading those stories
on the forums has been really fun to do
yeah yeah for sure
um maybe this is a little cheap but I
think my favorite has been actually the
last time we were here in this studio we
challenged everyone during quakecon to
run through dread sale Reef which was
one of our 12 player trials that we
released we had challenges along the way
we were taking shots of hot sauce wasn't
my finest moment
um but if they beat all of the bosses
they all won Alienware gaming monitors
and let me tell you it came down to
seconds like we had people on the side
telling us like you got to get offline
like there's other people that need to
go but it was really fun and I love
watching our players go through that
type of content yeah it was a real nail
bike yeah and for myself I think so I
love a lot of things about the high
aisle chapter and the character in the
story but I think my favorite thing was
the actual Tales of tribute questline
um it was the first thing I actually got
to work on as a quest designer in years
um and so just being able to like put
together a story that involves kind of a
group of Misfits who rather than like
solving problems by punching them in the
face they throw down cards and challenge
other clubs
yeah and so that was just it was
something kind of new and refreshing it
wasn't an end of the world or a big
political thing it was just a fun story
to tell
um and for anyone who's not familiar
Tales of tribute was the new uh ESO card
game that you can play in the game
itself uh which we'll hit on a little
bit more later in the Stream uh but the
other thing was I got to help create a
character known as bragus who uh is near
and dear to my heart one of my favorite
characters I've gotten to do and he was
voiced by the awesome Billy Boyd who
just knocked it out of the park and did
an amazing job yeah people love bragas
yes yeah yeah we were actually lucky
enough to have Billy Boyd on a stream
with us recently if you missed it it was
pretty recent you can search through the
vods but maybe after this stream yeah
hang out here first I saw him for like
two seconds and Gina kicked me out of
the stream I was like really boy
cause I'm curious
how to express my love through chat so
maybe he saw it I don't know well Billy
has um he's kind of been part of the eso
Community since we added him in the game
and he actually has a special message
for everybody that we wanted to share
hello everyone it's me it's bragas
professional car player and
semi-professional everything else
now I hope to see you in a Tavern very
soon playing Tales of tribute it's a
fantastic game and I am amazing at it so
come and find me I'll show you the rules
and you can join in the tales of tribute
I will say Billy is just as nice and
funny as he appears in these videos he
really is we're really lucky to be able
to work with him
um all right so we are wrapping up this
year's story with the final DLC which is
fire song and why everyone is here today
just a reminder this is coming to PC on
November 1st and on consoles on November
15th and let me just say this art is so
cool like this might be one of our
favorites that we have done for a DLC
yeah our team always knocks it out of
the park it really is great
maybe we'll do some wallpapers of this
or something let me just sign him up for
some work right up in game if you can
hear me all right all right so um let's
just kind of briefly go over everything
that is coming in the fire song DLC
yeah so with the fire song DLC uh it's
our fourth quarter DLC so you can expect
uh what you usually get in a fourth
quarter dlc about 15 hours of content
but this time it's centered around kind
of The Druids of uh Galen which is the
island that you're going to be visiting
um this is really the first time we've
deep dived into Druid lore and kind of
uh the Bren uh significance and why
that's all linked uh you know it's the
legacy of the brands and the year of the
brand so you know just how is that all
connected why are Druids involved um
it's actually there's quite a bit of
history in lore and we get to explore
that the other thing is you're going to
get to explore the island like I said
the island of Galen which is the third
major island in the sisters archipelago
you won't imagine how many people that
took me to say that word
um uh but yeah so you'll get to explore
a brand new island to the north of all
the other Islands uh and as always it
has its own set of like interesting
locations ends and side quests unique
rewards Collectibles antiquities you you
name it uh we have it delves all that
fun stuff so uh yeah it's I'm really
looking forward to players uh hopping in
on live and playing it all right so
Jason you touched on Galen a little bit
why don't we do a little bit of a deep
dive into the zone and some of the
inspiration behind it yeah so Galen and
fire song itself is the home of the
direct Clans there's three direct Clans
and we've met some of them so far we
have the stone Lords Roots they're kind
of like the peaceful Druids who live
amongst the others on the island uh in
our open communication and working one
amongst each other then we have the
evertide who is kind of like if you've
met them in the chapter they hate
everyone they're kind of crazy
um but when you meet them in fire song
they're they still hate Outsiders they
don't trust people but they're a little
bit more willing to work with you and
then there's the mysterious fire song
um a clan that's really kind of
entrenched in the old ways and they want
to reunite the people
um or the Druid Clans who used to be one
clan known as The Druids of Galen and
they want to bring them back and they
have good reasons for it in addition to
that though you also how house mernard
who is was a secondary house kind of in
the chapter you learned a little bit
about I've even met some of the
characters but they are kind of the main
um I guess Protectors of the island
they've come in and they've set up the
city of Bastyr uh and kind of live
amongst The Druids and everything like
that but the island itself is definitely
crazy it's more wild and overtaken than
aminos and high aisle was and it's
definitely kind of a cool place to run
around
kind of just going through the different
areas you'll explore as we mentioned
kind of the southern area itself is
Warehouse Menard in the city of astir
kind of is located that's the colonized
area where a lot of the brands have
built up their castles and you know kind
of live amongst The Druids and the vast
air with these giant like Stone carved
walls and buildings and everything like
that so you're going to see a lot of
that along the kind of the southern
coast as you explore as well as a lot of
similarities to what you would see in
high aisle because it is just the
northern section so you're going to have
Open Fields a lot of sunflowers things
like that it starts getting really
exciting when you start going to the
west where you start getting into the
more forested areas the big kind of the
home of The Druids places where they've
lived for hundreds and hundreds of years
and they've kind of made this where
they've you know where they habitat or
have a habitat right yeah I can say that
word but they live there and you can
tell it's an established place that's
been there for such a long time but
there's just lots of cool little touches
and hot springs and calderas and stuff
like that and then as you head to the
east you get to the jungles of Galen
which is my favorite where it's just
basically ginormous trees that are the
size of mountains flowers that are as
big as you and everything wants to kill
you there
um and you're also that sounds about
right yeah for Tamriel right yeah you
know in addition to all that there's
also lava spewing everywhere throughout
so you know if you step off step in the
wrong area you may lose a foot or a
giant mosquito made try to bite your
head off like there's there's lots and
lots of things that are looking to kill
you there so not the best vacations no I
I mean if you're into that like I mean
sure
no hard pass no all right so I imagine
with
a Zone where you have three pretty
different biomes it's got to be kind of
challenging for the team to figure out
how to make all of this transition well
together or maybe they're up for the
challenge maybe they can kind of you
know stretch their creative muscles a
little bit yeah
um I'd like to take more credit than I
actually uh deserve but I won't because
I I do very little with that it's like I
write something that's like give me lava
and and trees that are big
um it's a little bit more detailed than
that but uh the art team will go back
and they just they do such a great job
of sitting down and just doing concepts
of the different environments and one of
the hardest thing too is like figuring
out the transitions like how do you go
from something that's like Rolling Hills
and beautiful flowers to like overgrowth
and huge jungles and lava trying to you
know burn you and stuff like that so
they'll go down and they'll spend a
bunch of time like actually sketching
out the ideas of how this area
transitions to this area and then we'll
get into the world and the world
building team will go through and
they'll do their own pass and there's a
lot of trial and error and just getting
it to feel right but they do an awesome
job they Everything feels very natural
it feels like it's not just like I just
walked into a different game all of a
sudden so yeah I'm always in all of our
art team and all the amazing work they
do they want us to look very convincing
when you step into that Lobby yeah yeah
exactly it should hurt so as the Zone
lead
are you then kind of responsible for
sort of orchestrating all of this and
making sure that everything comes
together it makes sense yeah in a way
I'm kind of I guess you know the the
conductor I guess I kind of do a very
high level view of what we're putting
into the zone right the big story beats
um and then I also work with Bill
slavasek who is our lead writer and we
kind of get a lot of this stuff put
together and then we kind of make the
blueprint and then we hand it to the
team and we let the designers and the
writers and the art team and all that
they kind of figure it out there and
then I just kind of stepped back and I'm
there to help guide the process and
every now and then I'll help out and do
a little things like I may have some
stuff here and there that I've designed
and put in there but for the most part
yeah I'm just trying to make sure we put
out the best and most fun and enjoyable
uh you know experience that we can yeah
definitely takes a village to put
something like this together there are a
lot of teams and a lot of people
involved so with something like a new
Zone obviously we have to have really
cool new monsters so let's touch on
um some of the new monsters that are in
games yeah so one of the the most fun
parts of creating a new zone is thinking
up the things that are going to try to
kill you
um you know what yeah what fits
thematically with it you know what makes
sense from a lore standpoint like we do
a lot of digging into like the old lore
books and we use our Lore Master a lot
and like what makes sense here is there
something that was mentioned in a book
somewhere
um so there's a lot of Deep dive like
thinking into it's not just throwing
like darts at a dartboard being like Oh
today we got this
um but yeah so we've we a couple new
ones that are introduced in fire song
that we're really excited about uh the
first one is known as the forest wraith
uh the force wraith is essentially if
you were to take the embodiment of death
and evil but not in a necromantic way
but in a juridic way and you were to put
it inside of a creature and bring it to
life and then have this creature kind of
roam around the forest and try it and
Maul you and murder you that would be
the forest wraith why does anyone want
to move to Tamriel yeah that's a great
place the next thing is the Chimera uh
you know we Chimera is a famous creature
a lot of anyone who's familiar with any
type of Mythos Greek Mythos Etc is
familiar with the Chimera but we really
want to do our own take on it you know
what does a chimera look like in Elder
Scrolls so we put a wamasu head and a
griffin head and a lion head on and got
that the Chimera is super important just
because it also has a tie to The Druids
and then my favorite which we just saw a
little clip of the chunky fire boys
uh the magma frogs so there's a joke
every time I do a Zone uh I I got a frog
in in Blackwood for anyone you're
welcome
um and there's a lot of people are like
really do people really want to fight
frogs and I was like yeah people love
giant frogs I try to eat you
um and there was a lot of back and forth
and I got it and like a lot of people
really like the frogs and now every time
I do a release I'm like hey we gotta do
some frogs we gotta do some frogs and
they're like oh here comes Jason
Froggers again
um and what's funny is I don't like
frogs I just do that on spite no no
really well if you like them now and
this is your brand so it's
um Jason Frogman Barnes yeah live on
stream and we weren't even we weren't
even sure if we were going to get the
magma frogs but I kind of won a battle
of my own because like we went to the
drawing board and we were like hey let's
do a bunch of sketches of different
creatures that would fit in here and I
was
like
and they're like frogs really and they
went back and they did these awesome
sketches and what was the coolest the
frogs the frogs
can I ask real quick we were talking
about magma frogs how many times a day
did the team do magma
uh we may be showing our age too and we
looked this up the other day and I was
really upset with how long that movie
came couldn't believe how old that movie
is somebody in chat please say you get
the reference yeah please you don't
understand magma thank you okay thank
you there they go yeah liquid hot magma
yes okay we're good we haven't aged
ourselves too much chat recognizes yes
we're in good company it looks like
thank goodness yeah all right we're good
well speaking of Monsters uh they're not
the only things that players have to
contend with uh in Galen so what are
players walking into what is what's the
scene looking like
um yeah so when you show up in vastyr uh
in the main city like you're entering a
time of turmoil and chaos and just
everything's an upheaval uh there's a
lot of just conflict going on like house
Bernard itself is just struggling to
kind of survive the city itself is very
different than what you would need to
see in like Golfland Bay where it was
like pompous Nobles in a resort town
almost
um this is gritty workers and and people
trying to make it um and so
of course they weren't very happy when
all these sea elves have shown up uh and
CLS play a major role uh in this DLC
which I'm super psyched about because uh
I just I love CLS and anytime I'm like
we can use seals
um for anyone who played Dragon hold
there's a couple Dragon hold CLS I put
them there because I love them they are
my children now
um but yeah so uh you know house Minard
is being sieged by all sides by these
CLS for some reason they don't really
know why and they're much more organized
than they usually are and they're just
like attacking everywhere and you kind
of walk into this conflict and are
thrown immediately into it in addition
to that you also have this Druid Clans
who are kind of bickering amongst
themselves because the fire song wants
to unite The Druids again and kind of
bring them under something known as the
Druid King
and there's lots of reasons for why they
want to or don't want to but this is
also causing a conflict and everything
is kind of connected did in one way or
another in the background and as you
play through the story you'll kind of
start to see how and why but yeah if the
player doesn't do something like that
whole island is
done no pressure no pressure well along
with new monsters we love having brand
new characters that join us that you can
kind of learn more about so Jason what
are a couple of the new or interesting
characters that players can find in fire
songs yeah so
um I'm very character-centric so I'm
always excited when we're introducing
like main story characters you'll be
partnering up with a number of like
various Druid characters including
Laurel who you've met in the dungeons
there's a number of like house Bernard
Knights these those primarily make up
your cast of characters the two are most
excited about though is again I was just
talking about C elves and my love for
them is a new character known as Captain
servine of the Gilded Blade the CLS that
are causing problems on the island are
known are the dread sales uh malmer
which you've experienced if you played
the trial or the dungeons her group has
a little different view on what they're
doing and uh might be making some people
mad back in their Mainland so super
excited for players get to get to meet
her and then the other character I'm not
going to reveal anything really about
but it's a new character spoiler phrase
free uh and it's a character unlike
anything we've done before and the team
and everyone are just very excited to
bring this character to life so
um yeah I'll be curious to see people's
reaction to that because free is pretty
cool yeah well hint I'm not I'm not
going to speak for Dom but I am because
he doesn't have a mic right now maybe we
will do so meet the character articles
on these characters coming on the eso
website hopefully soon I did want to
mention real quick I saw some people in
chat mentioning how cool the plushes are
on our table here we have a Gwar and a
mud crab maybe you might want to stick
around because we might be giving those
away a little bit later in the Stream So
wouldn't it be cool if we had a magma
frog
that would we'll get on that yeah maybe
we should
have the marketing folks sticking over
there
in the meantime we are very excited to
give everybody an exclusive first look
at the eso fire song Gameplay teaser
trailer so enjoy
Invaders
destroyers
Bringers of ruin
the Druid King's dream lives on in me
again
and there you have it the first premiere
of fire song
well we're going to shift gears a little
bit from that and we're going to be
talking about what else you can do in
fire song outside of the main quest line
so uh Jason you want to chat about that
a bit Yeah so um you know in addition to
everything that we kind of chatted about
and kind of the stuff that you know we
you come to expect when you're when
you're doing a fourth quarter DLC we
always like to add kind of our own
little fun I don't know just like things
we just like what would we like to see
in the game yeah just other things to do
yeah you know killing and murdering
exactly I mean that's fine you want to
run around pick flowers that's also fine
good for you
um but a lot of times we do that through
achievements
um and so this time around we we want to
do some kind of fun and unique
achievements for anyone who's been
playing our content of late you may have
noticed that you can pet more and more
things in the game animals animals you
can't pet your companions stop it
don't even try no that's all they're
going to be asking for yeah um but um it
started with like petting a dog and then
we were dancing with dogs now we were
picking up cats and it just it's kind of
expanded
um over time we even got the attention
of can you pet the dog yeah I think we
Twitter account yeah they're like hey
you can't pet the dog in ESO and we took
that personally they were like now you
can't
um and so we just keep adding more and
more and there's even more animals you
can interact with I'm not going to give
it away uh but so we decided you know
what
why don't we have an achievement like
let's make an achievement so you can go
around and interact with all the
interactable animals I'm not saying
every animal that you see there's a
number of them
um and it's achievement called the best
of friends it's my favorite achievement
it's got a cute little cat that you're
petting on it
um and we uh recently updated it so it's
kind of like a little clue it's almost
like a scavenger hunt when you go around
and find the pets but super excited
about that and they're just like fun
stuff like there's a lot of lava on our
zone right there's a lot of spriggins in
our Zone those two don't really mix so
uh if you see one you get the uh prompt
to kick one in lava do it you see what
happens do it and we want to see clips
of it yeah this is how you get the
achievement yeah there you go 36 more to
go exactly
um but we'll also be bringing back World
bosses uh so some of the creatures that
we saw earlier of our new uh the new
monsters are our world boss versions and
then we also have the volcanic vents uh
for anyone who's not familiar with those
basically group events in the world that
when you're running around they'll spawn
up randomly and they'll require you and
a couple people to go and do um so super
excited about that now something we know
that players really liked in one of the
previous DLCs was actually wandering
World bosses because World bosses
they're challenging but the wandering
ones is like
watch out stomp on you anytime and we
actually put one of those in fire songs
yeah there's a couple
um so the encounter team who does like
all the monsters and stuff they really
enjoy doing it in dead lands and when we
were coming around for this one we're
like hey should we do something similar
uh and they're like yeah yeah we really
want to do this so
um if you're wandering around just be
really careful because there's some
ginormous spriggins getting ready like
ready to step on you don't get stopped
unless you're into that but whatever
that's for a different stream
so we talked a lot about
um oh I'm sure they're fine don't worry
um we talked a lot about new monsters we
talked about characters what are um
what are maybe some returning characters
that we've seen before yeah maybe people
will get a little excited yeah so uh
returning characters are near and dear
to my heart I think everyone who works
on the team
um you know whether it's rigor the Brash
or Stevens and Lauren um just characters
we tend to use those two are not in it
so that's not it
um I wouldn't just give it away that
quickly but no so we're always looking
for kind of new characters that would
fit the theme of the story and like
what's going on and where would they fit
in and who can we bring back and what's
kind of going on
um
not Darian sorry chat right now I'm just
gonna get that so much disappointing
yeah
um but yeah so the first character I'm
super excited about I think a lot of the
eso Community is super uh we'll be super
excited to see him again it's the old
Razzle Dazzle himself razzam Dar uh he
has returned on a mission for the eyes
of the queen uh and he's kind of getting
up to no good as Raz does and so you'll
be joining him on a little Adventure
throughout the island to see what's
going on
um but yeah Raz is awesome they're
excited the other character that I'm
super excited about is a character we
haven't actually seen in a long time uh
as a matter of fact we've only seen her
once uh and it was back in the days of
the Thieves Guild uh that is the lovely
Quinn uh who we are super excited to
bring back
um she uh is on a heist or an adventure
of her own that she will need your help
in and as always if you've met her and
done the Thieves Guild she'll remember
you and act like your old buddy and if
you haven't then she is uh you know this
is her first mission she's trying to
like gear up for the Thieves Guild so
um it's always fun writing the
characters and bringing them back
especially with someone like Quinn where
like I said we just haven't seen him
forever the designer who did her class
was very very excited to be able to use
Quinn so so with all of these characters
and a lot that
um the community is really kind of
gravitated towards as being some of
their favorites how does the team decide
which characters to bring back
so a lot of times we we I mean we almost
have like a list of like characters like
we really want to use this
um yeah but it really is just kind of
who's designing what uh who's writing it
possibly
um and what is the story like we never
want to feel like we're just gonna force
a character into something just to do it
um so it it has to fit it has to make
sense so a lot of times we'll be like
okay you know Quinn's for example deals
with the sea elves and it's a heist so
it was like okay it makes sense
sprinkling back so like our designer
Janet really want it to be like yeah let
me use Quinn and we're like yeah awesome
we haven't seen Quinn in Forever that'd
be great
um so we there is quite a bit of
discussion about it as well as the voice
actors you know who are we getting in
the studio not all of them are available
if someone's in you know vacationing and
uh you know the island somewhere we not
might not be able to use them so there's
there's a lot that goes into it a lot of
moving parts so you don't just pull
names out of the house no that'd be cool
though
I was gonna say that sounds like a
challenge scenario here's the character
put them together there you go well next
time I'm in the office I want to see the
supposed list of suppose I actually have
an Excel spreadsheet there you go maybe
uh looks Jason to give us give us a
little peek someday so obviously there
is a lot to do in fire song one thing we
did want to bring up though is something
that we call bonus quests now this is
really cool we have a really great one
this time we want to make sure nobody
misses it so Jason first what are bonus
quests bonus quests are essentially the
resolution of the year-long storyline
they are a culmination of the main quest
from the chapter and the main quest from
the DLC so in this case High aisle and
Fire song
um it's basically the the bow to wrap
everything up at the end of the year uh
in this particular case uh it's going to
bring back characters uh from both the
DLC and the chapters such as lady
Arabelle as you've seen
and you're gonna finally figure out what
the ascendant order is up to and who the
ascendant Lord is and kind of
um
see why they're doing what they're doing
which uh you know has a time with the
legacy of the brands and all that and I
like how you're tiptoeing around again
very careful uh and I will say the team
did an awesome job we the final quest
without giving anything away is
something that
is unlike anything we've really done
before
um to the level that we're doing it
that's about as vague that I'm gonna
keep it there but I'm super excited for
people to play through it and just yeah
really proud of the team and all the
work they did yeah cool definitely well
it sounds like we've talked about
characters quite a few times
Arrow to your knee who's your favorite
who's your favorite so one character
that is coming back for the bonus quests
uh that is my personal favorite also
from the same DLC that uh this guy up
here is involved in is none other than
zaji and casca zaji specifically
um for anyone who doesn't know zaji I
mean just look at him a beautiful
beautiful Khajiit pirate
um he's just this very kind of
flamboyant active funny Lively character
that every time zaji's in a scene it
just kind of like it makes the scene
better
um and you know he was in Dragon hold he
was in our dungeon DLC he's been in high
L High aisle
um and the voice actor who does him Ben
diskin just does an amazing job like he
just he is Aji and when he whenever you
hear him you're like yes this is
beautiful this is right well it looks
like chat agrees with you yes a lot of
people love zombies and zaji is a great
choice but you know what else is a great
choice taking some time to go and play
Tales of tribute the new card game
released in uh High aisle uh it's a
pretty easy game to pick up but one
that's a little difficult to master and
if you need some tips there we've got
plenty of community members who are
really great at uh uh you know coaching
people through uh playing I was gonna
say winning but yeah well let me teach
you how to play you know pink pink Apple
on the Forum is a really good resource I
think they've been like top rank on the
leaderboards also right I think between
pink Apple and Jay heart like they're
neck and neck all the time so yeah
definitely check one of them out if
you're looking for some tips on how to
play they they will not lead you astray
for sure and well with fire song we've
got an additional Patron deck that
you'll have access to uh the Druid King
kind of fitting in with the themes of
high aisle the Druid King is a combo
based deck so you're going to want to
you know try to steamroll your opponents
with that you can play Tales of tribute
with high aisle and you'll have access
to the Druid King with fire song
but we've got a couple of other updates
uh coming with this DLC right you know
we do so actually with update 36 which
is our base game update this is free for
all players we have a number of things
that we are adding that everybody can
enjoy so one of the first things we're
excited to introduce is simplified
Chinese translations for text that will
be coming in update 36 along with
something called Target markers which is
exactly what they sound like it is when
you can kind of Mark a target a friendly
or a foe it's really helpful when you're
running through Dungeons and trying to
coordinate or even in PvP you can kind
of Mark which Target you want everybody
to focus on which is going to be really
great especially for some some of those
harder trials we're adding a toggle so
you can hide other players pets in towns
so if you just kind of want other
people's pets or companions or
assistants or what have you to get out
of the way you're trying to do your Ritz
no more bare butts no more Ward and bear
butts they are out of the way so you can
toggle that on and off at will we're
also introducing text to speech
specifically for chat so that'll
actually be coming to the pts next week
if everybody wants to try it out it's a
really great accessibility feature and
of course all of this stuff is detailed
on our website so be sure and head to
Elder scrollsonline.com if you want more
details about some of this
well those are a ton of updates coming
up um but here's how you can get ready
for fire song uh first of all if you
haven't played uh the legacy of the
breton's content you should definitely
hop on that right do it yeah you should
now go through that especially the main
quest line if you do the main quest line
and then play fire song that'll unlock
the bonus Quest
um and of course uh you know unlocking
all this uh will what it's out for or
it's on sale right now right
um and you know the prologue Quest on
top of that will be accessible right now
for all ESO players
um so with that uh Jason do you want to
chat about the uh prologue Quest a
little bit Yeah so first off uh the
prayer log quest which you can get now
uh it's live is on PC is free free you
get one you get one you get one
everybody gets one yeah uh but the big
thing about the prologue Quest is it is
a direct tie-in to fire song
um you're gonna kind of be introduced to
a couple of characters that will kind of
set up the story and kind of give you
your intro to what's going on and
without going into spoilers it's
basically the Druid king of old has left
something on the island that's of great
importance and there's another Druid
clan that is attempting to get it before
you so it's a Race Against Time to
uncover what that is and why but yeah
I'm super excited go go play it now go
do it after the stream not after this
stream yeah so yeah just a reminder that
the prologue Quest is part of the base
game free for all players available as
of this morning but maybe stick around
until after the stream to go check it
out yeah um if you want to pick up the
quest starter all you have to do is find
the NPC Druid Laurel in your alliance
starter City so you can head to Art on
stonefalls or glenumbra or you can
simply hop to the Crown store and pick
up the quest start Quest starter quest
Quest starter from right there once you
complete the prologue Quest there is a
unique reward it is the petal
presentation patient emote so once you
complete you can use that emote whenever
you want and of course as usual we have
a website article that has all the
details explaining where to go what to
do how to get all the stuff
so we do have a short video that we will
be playing for you in just a moment
we're going to peek in and see what Dom
is doing in terms of the prologue Quest
but first sadly it is time to say
goodbye to our friend Jason
Goodbye Jason Goodbye Jason lovely to
have you as always we really appreciate
all the stories that you gave and the
insight for fire song and I know
everyone's excited to play it yeah I'm
excited for everyone to get in and play
it thank you for everyone who's been on
PTS testing we've been reading through
the feedback and awesome job uh just in
general but yeah please go out and play
it the team's super excited and thank
you for having me on uh it's been really
fun I'm gonna steal this uh so if it's
gone when you come back that's why all
right well enjoy this video and we will
be right back
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
all right so you'll see Dom here hanging
out with some more of his friends back
in the dance party back in the dance
party so Dom is hanging out doing the
prologue Quest
Don did you want to show up there's okay
so there's Druid Laurel that is the NPC
that you need to try and find in order
to do
the free prologue Quest available
earlier today and he is
very helpfully showing you where you
need to go in the crown store in order
to pick up that Quest starter
right in there
appropriately named Quest starters
right under the very obvious prologue
all right well well just a reminder to
everybody we do have drops on if you
haven't received your Twitch drops yet
just make sure you link your ESO and
twitch accounts and we will be doing a
giveaway soon not right now but soon
first though we want to talk a little
bit about our new in-game event that
just recently started earlier today also
it's been a busy day yeah called Heroes
of high aisle what is going on in game
here geez
people are pulling up their fancy mounts
and everything the mount Flex
you know right what better time to flex
than uh during the stream here so yeah
in addition to the prologue Heroes of
high aisle also started earlier today
this is brand new event that just began
it is a celebration of high aisle our
newest Zone you can benefit from double
uh not double bonus XP
bonus drop rates you can earn event
tickets the impresario's there the whole
shebang everything you expect from
in-game events we also have a new
community challenge that just started
with this for this time we are
challenging everyone to complete the
high aisle Pathfinder achievement Now
Kevin what is the Pathfinder achievement
for maybe some of our newer players that
haven't tried this yet
so for those who haven't tried it yet
the Pathfinder achievement is a way for
you to you know see some of the coolest
places in all of high Isle you can do
this Solo or you can do this with a
bunch of friends but the whole goal is
to go around and check out High aisle
and when you complete the Pathfinder
achievement you will add progress to the
community bar and as you continue to
increase the community bar you will get
more loot and unlock a ton of new stuff
for uh your characters so you should
definitely go and do that and I mean you
guys have already gotten a head start
you're already at 15 yeah we're we're on
a good track yeah because we're actually
counting everybody who already did the
Pathfinder achievement prior to this
event starting so we're already at 15
yeah you're already you're already
winning
well let's check in with dom uh he's
going to complete some of this stuff for
Ohio right now
yeah so he is heading over
Dom open your map so everybody can see
if they want to show you
so yeah he is
running over to one of the six striking
locales that you need to do in order to
get the achievement so what's nice about
this too is because we have some players
that if as you saw have already
completed the achievement they already
know where to go and we've actually seen
players create accounts that's like
Pathfinder taxi or you know
High aisle Uber or whatever and they
will literally take newer players around
to help complete this achievement which
has been really helpful I think our
players are nice and welcoming yeah
definitely so checking on Dom is great
but let's talk rewards because I think
that's what people are really excited to
hear about right good stuff so let's get
into what exactly is at stake when
you're filling up this meter
so we're already 15 at 33 everyone will
receive the Oaks promise body and face
markings which you can see right here
at 66 percent we'll be giving everyone
an emote titled plant yourself
do you get why it's called plant
yourself yeah I could see it
it's cute at 100 though we will be
giving everyone something called the
ascendant horde box now this is like
it's boxes within boxes within boxes
it's like boxception so you got to make
sure you open all the boxes inside the
boxes are going to be things like an
ascendant Lord statue Furnishing we've
got crafting stations we've got item
sets we've got companion gear we've got
tokens we've got writing lessons there's
all this stuff in here so you got to
make sure you open all your boxes right
I see it in chat boxception exactly
that's not all friends we have another
thing we are giving everybody if we hit
100 on the meter
drum roll should we tell them what it is
yeah let's do it after this break
just kidding
final prize when you hit 100 for Heroes
of high aisle is going to be
the eso fire song DLC free for everybody
but you gotta hit 100 on the meter so
everything we just talked about in this
stream you will get for free if you hit
100 and if you own the high aisle
chapter very important right I'm glad
look how excited chat is they're so
stupid very pumped yeah they're super
pumped but
that's not all
so what else on top of all the loot the
loot the loot the free DLC on top of all
of that
for ESO Plus members you will be getting
this cute little guy the appleback
salamander
look at him look at his little fire
belly I don't know I would call him cute
but I think that's cool he'll he'll keep
you warm and on those cold Tamriel
nights when you're lost and lost in the
woods with these giant flowers Jason was
talking about so I'm throwing them at a
magma frog
so yeah this is exclusive for our ESO
Plus members really happy to give that
away but this is especially uh remember
you can only get this when the meter
hits 100 so this is just an added
incentive for everybody to participate
and you know start ferrying people to
all the Striking locales all the fun
places to go in Ohio so what I'm hearing
is it's really important people work
together and hit 100 during Heroes of
aisle right because then you can get all
this stuff you can get the boxception
thing you can get all the loot you can
get the free DLC and then if you're in
ESO plus member you get that awesome pet
on top of it it's like it's like things
for everyone right you get rewards and
you get Rewards well you know what they
say Gina Teamwork Makes the Dream Work
nailed it
all right so for those considering
participating
um all you need to do is grab the latest
chapter High aisle which is on sale
right now
um and you'll be able to start jumping
in either by yourself or the friends uh
to go and hunt down that Pathfinder
achievement
indeed
um and here's a short video to get us
started with high aisle
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
friends you have been so patient waiting
for this giveaway we keep teasing
throughout the stream so I think we're
gonna go ahead and get started with it
and again nothing
um so we will be giving everybody the
keyword in just a second but we will be
drawing two winners during the stream
today you will receive a high aisle
collector's edition and one of these
plushies either the mud crab or the Gwar
but we will draw two winners so the key
word it's not fire song good guess
though it's not frog but another really
good guess it is
magma
we had to do it right we had to do it it
was easy so we will draw two winners
you'll get the
um I don't know what I was about to say
but it wasn't High aisle the high aisle
collectors edition and one of these
plushies which you can see here we've
got the mud crab plushie we've got the
guar plush that looks like it's actually
my shoe but it's not it's not aguir
slipper see we'll petition for that
along with the magma frog there we go we
got our work cut out for us so if you're
interested in winning one of these items
all you have to do is type magma in chat
without the quotes but it would have
actually been funny if it was magma
moving on so the prologue Quest is live
here is a high isle is live all these
rewards are available for you to get but
what else is on the horizon
for people to participate in so
typically in the fall and winter in
Tamriel it's a little more fun it brings
some of our favorite events I'm actually
going to put this down because I keep
I'm a hand talker and I keep flinging it
around so there we go
um so all of our events in the fall and
winter including some of the returning
favorites do have new rewards so we'll
be going through these events in just a
moment we will have our events graphic
going up on social if it's not up
already not sure because you know we're
doing this but um yeah definitely keep
an eye out for that but in the meantime
we will tell everybody the events coming
yeah well to start off we've got witches
Festival uh coming in October uh this is
the time where you can celebrate all the
spookiness in Tamriel
um and you've we've got ton of Fun
Collectibles for you to collect uh and
you know we also have a lot of community
Creations that people have done
throughout uh various old activities uh
so you'll see those on screen right now
but
um those showcase some of the uh things
that people have collected over the
years and a you're able to get for a
witches Festival
um
this is also the opportunity for you to
start uh getting that Morgan collectible
keep an eye out on that yeah so if you
missed it um it's actually something
that the community has been asking for
for a really long time and this is a
Furnishing that allows you to control
the time of day in your house so it'll
allow you to come up with some pretty
cool screenshots I think
um so the next event is Dark Art of
Skyrim celebration this is happening in
November this is a celebration of all of
our Skyrim content as you just saw on
the screen we have bonus rewards for
completing questing and exploring
throughout Western Skyrim Blackreach and
the reach
capital t uh just a reminder when we
have all of these different zones you
can explore you can do it in any order
there's no linear path so that makes it
a little bit easier
and then we're going to round out the
year with the New Life Festival uh this
is your time to uh gather with everybody
in Tamriel to celebrate the end of the
year and we'll have plenty of unique
rewards quests and hopefully you'll
celebrate with some Mead
um but you're probably wondering how do
you participate in all of these various
activities can you do them Solo or can
you do them as a group do you have to do
them as a group I'm here to tell you you
can do it however you want you can play
solo you can play with a group of people
and the we've got various ways for you
to be able to find uh groups to play
with we've got our in-game uh group
finder we've got Zone chat just shout
out when you need help and there's
definitely somebody who's going to be
around to help and you can also go into
some of our Forum uh threads we've got
plenty of pages for uh people to join
guilds or group up with people like I
mentioned earlier you've if you want to
grab a a game of tales of tribute that's
also a place to go yeah and just a
reminder we also have a nice Guild
finder in-game too so if you're looking
for a specific group of people doing
specific content if you're looking for
maybe PVP or crafting role play If
you're looking for maybe a certain
language all of that is in there in the
filters so you can search for guilds
that are off looking for new players to
join in
so if this is intriguing to you if you
decide to pick up either the base game
or high aisle
why not both now is a great time because
the base game and the chapter sales are
live now for a limited time
so be sure
and check it out now I think we are
going to be ending our giveaway in just
a moment
maybe final seconds to get your entries
in because we are going to be drawing
winners for the Plushies that are right
down here and high collectors Editions
should we announce the winners
sure draw and announce
that's my horrible drum roll I didn't
want to fling this this thing off here
all right first winner is going to be
Camry P99 or maybe it's cam rip 99 I
went with Camry because I recognized it
from the car yeah anyway I do the same
second winner go ahead Kevin with this
one oh uh babe Steger
stegor babies
sturgor
in any case we've got your name so we'll
congratulations yeah we will contact you
okay your shipping address everybody
congratulate the winners for today
the font doesn't stop there though folks
so we do have a number of fun fall and
winter activities outside the game too
that you can look forward to one of
which is test October we recently posted
the social graphic a few days ago this
will be starting on October 1st though
it's actually our third year running
test October where we challenge our
players to come up with some really cool
creations based on prompts that we
Supply so this is one example from a
previous year that we saw and I tell you
the community really comes together and
is so creative yeah you all deliver
every single time oh for sure so we also
recently wrapped up our sea shanty
contest we will be announcing those
winners early next week on the eso
website and we're really excited to
bring back a holiday themed art contest
now we haven't done one of these since
2017 but this was our winner from years
ago from the last time we did a holiday
themed art contest so stay tuned to the
website we will be posting details on
that soon
we also see our community really come
together in the fall and winter months
to run amazing content now this includes
things like a themed housing decorating
contest we know folks like Aries summer
is always looking at really cool housing
Creations J Hart we mentioned earlier
like we have a bunch of streamers and
content creators that love showcasing
all of the housing decorations we also
have a guild they're called Vanquish
they put on a live in-game ESO Christmas
Carol play every year
seating is extremely limited and I mean
they go nuts for this it is a whole set
they have costumes they write the whole
script it's crazy so because seating is
very limited maybe we'll live stream it
for everybody so you can check it out
because it is very impressive
so we have lots of players looking for
things to do we have a great community
so we definitely encourage you to hop in
look for a guild find some friends and
join us this holiday season
but if all of that wasn't enticing
enough we've got another uh way for you
to or another reason for you to log in
we've got the nowhere pack available
through
um our two promotions with uh Xbox game
pass ultimate and Amazon Prime gaming
you'll be able to see uh on the screen
here the uh matching Mount and uh pet
and the two crates that you can get with
the nowhere pack and those will be
available until November 8th it's a nice
little matching set too if you're
looking for a nice you know Mountain Pet
set it's free so why not grab it right
um and lastly we've got the black
freedis bundle a new black redis bundle
that will be available in November
um and we'll have more details on that
soon
so my friends
Kevin that brings us to the end of our
stream today
we talked about a lot of stuff so let's
just quickly recap for everybody all the
things we went over yeah definitely so
base game and the chapter are both on
sale right now
uh Heroes of high isle is live and
remember the community challenges up as
well so that once you get a hundred
percent on that uh challenge meter you
get the fire song DLC for free
did you all hear that we're giving the
DLC for free free 99. but you gotta hit
100 on the meter and you gotta own high
aisle
which is on sale so we know you can do
it you've done it in previous years we
believe in you you can work together and
get this done we're excited to give it
away to everybody so they can play
what else did we talk about fire song of
course arrives November 1st for PC and
then November 15th for Xbox and
PlayStation consoles it is also
available on the pts right now that is
our public test server so if you have an
active PC account
you can actually download the PTS
completely free you can check out maybe
do a little first look at some of this
content yep and on top of that we've got
the fire song prologue Quest that is
available to all ESO uh
people
everybody in veteran in Tamriel um it's
it's available right now uh go ahead log
in and check it out on top of that we've
got uh test October starting October 1st
yep and don't forget to claim your
Twitch drops we gave away this really
cool pet we gave away maybe multiple
crates depending on how long you've been
watching but you have to make sure you
link your accounts and you have to make
sure you claim them so head over to
twitch.tv drops there is a very obvious
claim button there as soon as you do
that it'll show up in game
you can break out your cool pet and
everyone be like oh where'd you get that
got it from the legacy of the bretton's
autumn event of course yep best stream
right so we are actually going to be
rating one of our stream team partners
ninja614 the one and only yeah he is
going to be doing the heroes of high
aisle events so if you're looking for
some help
you can log in or you can watch his
stream maybe he'll give you some tips
but yeah now's a good time we do want to
thank everybody for joining us today we
had a great time we hope you did as well
we will see you next time thank you so
much bye everyone bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]